hey what's up my name is Matt woods and
I'm gonna talk a little bit today about
how I landed my dream software job in
about twelve months you see I'm
relatively new to development and all
this kind of stuff and but I've always
loved computers I've always come in
nerded out over technology and was big
into video games and always was kind of
the go-to tech person with computers and
everything but it wasn't until I like a
couple years ago that I really bear down
and get serious about software got
involved in like a coding boot camp and
like really started to run with it and
learn JavaScript and learn some PHP and
different things
and it eventually getting involved in
the community all these crazy things and
so I'm gonna I'm gonna talk a little bit
about basically my journey for about a
year ago when I went to my first
software development conference with
Thunder Plains and how the people I met
there and the habits I built along the
way helped me actually get a full-time
job that were actually the ship code to
production where I work on an awesome
marketing team and get to use the best
parts of marketing that I love and in
development and get to bring those two
skills together and some skills that
like whether you're you're more in the
technical side or whether you want to
work on a software business just some
stuff that anyone can pick up and use
but it's mainly going to focus on kind
of the development side of that and so I
remember man when I started this journey
I wa you know like twelve eighteen
months ago and I had never really
touched JavaScript before I was always
someone who had like poked around with
HTML and CSS it kind of stayed in my
lane could have done some friends stuff
I think messed around with like booster
abs and some styling things like made
some quick tweaks on websites maybe
messed around with some WordPress themes
but I never really liked Doug and then
build something from the ground up but
build something that I can say like that
it was original that I had made it I had
an idea in my head and I wrote some code
and I made it work and then I think back
and compare that to the past few weeks
and things I've been working on where
I've actually gotten to to pair unreal
like code that's gonna go production
with like the co-founder of the startup
that I'm working at that has you know
twenty eight people in Oklahoma City in
New York
we have you know thousands and thousands
of people that use our app we're
tackling real code and I'm getting to
actually see work that I do go out into
the real world and be seen by more
people than I ever thought possible
which totally just blows my mind and I
couldn't know that the things that I was
I'd hoped that the things I was learning
would be that applicable but it's a good
whole different thing to actually see it
in action some other crazy things that
have happened recently is just being
able to build my network and meet other
people in software and be able to like
really advance my career by leaps and
bounds to the point where like I wanted
to get to know other people in this area
that I'm looking to grow in this growth
professional area where you're kind of
combining engineering and marketing and
the best parts of both and so I decided
to go on kind of this connection spree
and reach out to a bunch of people who
knew this better than I did so I reached
out to people from Facebook and Spotify
and Airbnb and Pinterest and Google and
all like the companies that I think the
best companies I could think of that
actually have these growth teams that
combined engineering and marketing and
as it will connect with 25 really
qualified people in less than 24 hours
because of the connections I've been
able to make habitually with some of the
stuff I'm gonna talk about in a little
bit and that's been a huge game-changer
for my career and just even going beyond
Oklahoma City with some of the
connections I've been able to make as
well as just like getting involved with
events and different being able to share
my work out in public and it's opened
doors to meet founder CEOs and excellent
engineers and marketers from all kinds
of awesome companies in Oklahoma City
but also in Boston and San Francisco and
other places and I've actually gotten to
meet some of them face to face and
that's been a total game-changing
experience and I've made lots of
valuable connections that I treasure to
this day and I'm hoping it's just the
beginning I'm so I'm gonna talk about
how that happened too but really if I
had to like narrow down the three things
that were I want to talk about these
three key habits that kind of open the
door to me being able to step into my
dream job and software I'd say that
there were these three things I'm gonna
go more in depth on each of these the
first habit is becoming an automatic
learning machine and I'm going to talk
about what that means in kind of how you
can build that up yourself
the second thing
building a three circle Network and I'll
explain what those three circles are and
why each of them matter and you have to
do them in sequence and then the last
step is sharing your byproducts
basically as you're learning the stuff
how you can put it on the world to not
only help other people but to help
yourself
I get the job and the and do the work
that you want to do and live the life
you want to live because that's why
we're doing this stuff so anyways I'll
have to say hi my name is Matt I'm a
marketer and developer at tailwind right
now you can check me out on Twitter at
mataf or tweet me with any questions or
follow-up stuff you have after this or
you check my website at Matt woods dot
IO and we are always hiring at tailwind
so if you're interested in kick starting
your development career or making a
change always let me know happy to chat
about that too
but I want to dive into this first habit
is becoming an automatic learning
machine I think more than anything this
is the thing that enabled me to make the
jump from what I was doing before which
is like working at a marketing agency
and hop into a software startup at talen
where I'm actually shipping code and
doing these things and so I was at the
marketing agency when I was like
starting to kinda jump into this coding
journey but I wasn't really sure where
to start and I think like a lot of
people I I kind of had this feeling I
was talking to a buddy
earlier this week who's just getting
started in coding and one of his number
one questions was basically why am I
feeling so happy hen civ towards getting
involved in new projects and getting
started in coding on and it's a really
good question and I think it's one that
pretty much everyone feels when they're
getting started and my answer is like
you know to fight that apprehension that
everyone feels that you need to give
yourself more wins you need things that
you're gonna feel good about that you
can play plant a flag in the ground and
say hey I built this I did this I feel
good about this coding is exciting it's
not easy but I did it and I want to do
more of it so how do you get those wins
well it doesn't just happen it doesn't
just fall in your lap this stuff is hard
but the way that you get better
to get those wins is you have to ship
more
and when I say ship you know it's not
like you know Carnival Cruise Lines type
of thing we're talking about taking a
piece of code a project something and
putting it out in the world where it's
you know it may not be quote-unquote
finished and perfect but it is done and
you were getting it out in front of real
people real users real getting real
feedback in the real world I saw this
tweet the other day about one of my
buddies Ezra who also started kind of
learning to code or on the same time
that I did and I thought it was really
insightful what he said was the biggest
challenge I feel as a new or fresh
developer is always comparing myself to
other developers and I always get stuck
wondering how they got there versus just
learning how to work on stuff myself and
does talk about this discipline of like
putting your head down and building code
is just something we all have to learn
we all have to get better at and because
it's the only way that you get better I
think one of the mistakes when when you
get started with this habit of learning
to code two is that you wanna you want
to start really big you want to make the
full app with like the the billing and
the cool feature and this crazy
marketing sign it looks slick and it
like give us some slack a run for their
money but I think actually the best way
to go around this is to start small and
consistent I read this book about how to
basically create a habit of learning
that really transformed the way I think
about this and that I still reference it
to this day and it's called the one
thing by Gary Keller and he the way he
talks about is like if you want the best
chance to succeed at anything you want
your approach should always be the same
you have to go small because if you go
too big you're not going to build up
this feedback loop of getting a good you
know doing something hard but rewarding
getting the win learning from it doing
something a little bigger getting the
win right if you if you start too big
you're never gonna get that feedback
you're never gonna get that win and
you're not gonna stay with it and so
many people drop off and I came close at
times like it can be really discouraging
when you're getting started but sticking
it out can make such a big difference I
think really building this coding habit
to comes down to these two things
Healthe input
healthy outputs just like you know any
any good system is gonna understand its
inputs and outputs you are a system when
you're learning to code and you have to
understand what you're putting into your
learning environment to succeed and what
what what you're outputting into the
world to make it an ultimate success and
so in terms of input what are you
putting in so this can look different
for different people but some examples
are like tutorials of like a lot of
different classes is there more
accessible than they've ever been online
you can draw in classes which is one of
the things I did you can listen to
podcast things like syntax and
full-stack radio and different great
podcasts where developers that can
supplement things in in your learning
journey you can go to event
these can be virtual events these can be
real event I recommend both even
checking out blog post basically does
anywhere you can get information that
will put new ideas that will show you
how to do things that will reinforce
things you already know you need to be
putting the right things in to fuel your
learning engine but then one of the most
common traps that I have definitely felt
myself starting to slip towards at times
is you can get in kind of this like it's
kind of like Groundhog Day but with
tutorials where you're just watching
someone else build something and then
you're parroting them and just like
typing out the same stuff and then
you're not doing anything yourself
you're not actually internalizing any of
it you're just copying a bunch of
tutorials you're reading a bunch of blog
post but you're not actually you're not
actually producing anything if someone
asked you to sit down and code even a
simple to-do app you would freeze or you
get stuck or you'd have to go find
someone else's finished work which isn't
what you want you want to be able to
understand and internalize the
fundamentals enough to do great work
yourself and so you need outputs right
you need to create a forcing function
but for yourself to ship and when I say
forcing function this is something that
is like an external pressure or
something that that helps motivate you
to actually get something done it can be
like a mentor who holds you accountable
it can be a small group it can be like a
deadline that you give yourself to make
sure that you actually follow through
otherwise when things get hard you'll
just stop or put it aside you'll think
maybe I'll get to this later I'll learn
this is the right way to do
later but the reality is you don't
always get there and then you're stuck
so we don't want that situation either
so this can look different for every
person it will look different for every
person but for me some of the inputs
that really helped me first of all it
was okay coders and this is a phenomenal
program if you're in the Oklahoma City
area
okay coders is like a bootcamp kind of
so it starts out it like HTML CSS and
goes into JavaScript and you have some
projects that you work towards at the
end and you work with the team and
you're taught by real developers in the
community and so it was great just for
me as kind of like it was actually a
little bit of both I got to learn some
of the fundamentals I got to practice
them and I was motivated and excited
enough from that input of being in that
class a couple times a week to go on
home and practice every single night and
reinforce that learning habit which
makes a huge difference I can't tell you
how many of my teammates were so excited
but they just didn't do the practice at
home and so some of it just didn't stick
which is so frustrating because I know
like before the last couple of years I
started and stopped a few times because
it just hadn't stuck so super easy to
slip into but if you can get excited
enough and then have that forcing
function of hey we got this big project
hey I get out gotta show this this new
thing I'm working on next week's class
it'll force you to ship it'll force you
to get stuff done and that can be
invaluable tutorials can be great I
learned really well by like watching
videos and then putting it aside and
like doing it on my own and that's my
learning style but it's gonna be
different for every person so figure out
what works well for you if it works to
like go through just read the
documentation and just freestyle it
great awesome
if videos work well for you too cool do
that but just experiment with a few and
figure out what works for you as an
input podcast can be great I just enjoy
podcasts anyways and so I'm gonna listen
to them and that they might as well be
helping me learn different things get
exposed to new ideas and so it it's just
one of those things that this really
hurt it's not gonna like teach me how to
write a good function or or like
organize my code well but it'll get
exposed
new ideas and keep me excited and
motivated which in itself is really
valuable and then events I'm gonna talk
more about events in a little bit but
super valuable and there's a lot of
stuff that goes along with events that
you really can't get any warehouse in my
opinion and so highly highly recommend
local and and online events and
communities if you're able to get
involved with that as far as output the
two things that really made a big
difference for me is number one
like mentors I'll talk a little bit
about this in a little bit but having
mentors who are at the next step ahead
of you who have to actually done this
stuff and can give you feedback give you
some tough love can help you ship stuff
is super valuable when you were learning
to actually ship this stuff and get it
out the door as well as like actual work
projects when I was able to take some of
the advanced like CSS stuff I was
learning implement a little bits of
JavaScript like even at my last job
before I joined Halon getting able to
put that to work on projects that the
the company was getting paid for was
super valuable and so that the sooner
you can get to that and actually work it
into your day-to-day work the better the
sooner you can actually create projects
that people use or you use yourself that
is a huge win so whenever possible I
highly recommend aiming for that all
right other things that help with
shipping I'm focusing a lot on shipping
because this is like really the
transformational thing that will
separate you from like a hey I want to
do code I want to be a programmer but
just kind of that want to be wishful
thinking stage to actually doing it
actually achieving it actually being
ready for the job or the opportunity
when it comes along because reality is
like the opportunity can come on but the
right opportunity if you're not ready
for it will like totally crush you or
totally disappoint you because you're
not ready for you haven't put in the
hard work I've actually I'm actually
doing this stuff but if you have is
gonna feel so good and it's actually
easier if you keep doing smaller
projects all on the way rather than just
trying to cram it in or like just
force-feed your self documentation or
something like that so some of the stuff
that I actually ship they got me ready
for the stuff I do today
all kinds of stuff but sort of more
original stuff it's like I built like a
habit tracking app in okay coders which
was fun we did like we use like PhoneGap
in cordova like basically built this
like a website that would load on your
phone and like you could load it in iOS
and Android and that was like super fun
and we built this app called like 21
that would help people to habit over 21
day it's a super exciting another one
that we did actually four or talen
before I joined that's kind of like an
okay coders project it was like this
search tool where we took it a bunch of
data and we were able to organize it by
categories and make these different
pages like these certain types like
Pinterest pins then we could search
through it and only returned certain
pins based on the search query to the
user
we used react for that and so it was a
great way to like cut her teeth on Java
scripts and actually build something
that was like really useful and as an
example of the kind of thing that we
like might actually build sad and
tailwind and so that was really exciting
there were also some things I did that
just kind of scratch my own itch I
decided that I wanted to learn to build
an API so I just did it I met with my
mentor he gave me some some tips on how
to actually do this stuff and I would
build some of it show him the code he
would show me how to make it better show
me the next thing to do okay great you
wrote the you wrote it let's write some
tests for it let's actually add on to it
let's create something to see some data
into it and work with the file system
doing all these things so I learned a
lot on that project I was also just
doing these like quick projects of like
creating a blog or redoing my personal
website or making like a random quote
generator and so just these quick and
easy like front kind of front-end stuff
that were fun that we're interactive
that keep you motivated and are not that
bad to to create once you get in the
habit of it some other ways to get ideas
for things that you can be shipping so
you can just ship more because really
the more you ship the more you'll come
up with ideas the more you'll understand
what to learn like this really is like
the linchpin a habit that helps you that
helps make everything after it easier to
the 20% you can focus on they'll make
the other 80% that people normally worry
about when they're running to code so
much easier trust me I wish I'd done
this more when I
getting started but a few ideas that
that I highly recommend to my friends
when they were running to code one is
like pair with someone who actually
shipped so if you know a developer if
you know someone who actually works on
this kind of stuff who is shipping code
regularly it was being used by people or
who always comes up with great site
project ideas just like get with them
and say hey can I just watch you code or
hey can we work on this small part of
this idea I have together or hey can we
grab coffee and like walk through this
thing and actually the faster you can
get into real code the better I think
I've learned more from actually pairing
over real code with like the developers
I work with then than any other than any
other thing that I've done it is
insanely productive if you can it can be
kind of scary because you know you're
gonna have to look stuff up in real time
or what if I make a mistake with this
person is no way more than me I'll feel
really dumb but it's really just
something you have to get over because
the learning is worth it it's so worth
it another thing that you can do that I
like to try as sort of copying on easy
mode so what I mean by this is there are
tons of apps out there that you probably
use every day you know like slack like
your to-do list
like like yet another email tool that
you know people use these you know
people need these and so it's not really
a question of like if this is a good
idea or not it's just a question of can
you build this or not like the the
MailChimp or slack or like these these
super popular apps everyone knows that
they want them or even like uber what if
you could take that app and just make a
super simple easy version of that super
simplified down or maybe you focus on
the design you just break off a small
piece what if you just made like a
really simplistic version of MailChimp
what if you just made a like a clone of
ubers like homepage what if you just you
know you can pull some of these ideas
and it can make it sort of easy for you
to get started because you're just
copying someone else's idea and putting
your own spin on it
they're actually hooked you'd hold
tutorial sites that just focus on sort
of this thing of making an easy clone so
it's a really fun way to do this and it
can feel good too because you feel like
oh I
I understand why this company did it
this way it's really motivating another
thing that I really like is this Airbnb
you tend to one exercise so this is an
exercise that air B&B is one of their
founders kind of goes through when he's
thinking of like a new experience or
product to create so he will think of
like okay if I'm trying to create like a
vacation for someone what is the
absolute best vacation that could create
like ten out of ten scale like what is
the or like I think actually goes from
one to ten so it'll be like what's the
worst experience okay you go to like
your Airbnb and nobody's there right and
you just leave in your super frustrating
you want your money back okay what's
like a good experience like a five out
of ten okay they go in there they show
you your room it's fine it's clean it's
a reasonable price good location
cool awesome what about like like a nine
or ten out of ten though there's like a
parade when you get in they know your
favorite candy like everyone welcomes
you in it's like the Beatles like
rolling into town like you exclusive
reservation of the finest restaurant
kind of the ultimate experience you can
do this and then like he will take the
like the ultimate one with this crazy
like over-the-top like experience and
he'll pare it down step by step until he
gets to something that's between like
terrible why very achievable and like
exceptional that's like what he builds
you can do the same thing with your app
so if you think like okay I'm gonna make
you know a you know a recipe app what is
the ultimate recipe app okay like reads
my mind I don't like understand like all
my dietary habits and what grocery
stores are closest to me what it's
building my list and it just it
integrates with Syria you can think of
all these crazy features that could have
and then you can strip those away one by
one by one and bring it down a level and
bring it down a level and that can
somewhere and there you may find a
really unique approach you wouldn't
normally think of that you can still
actually build or build a copy of that
or build a mock of the other builds
something and that can be a creative way
to get a cool idea that you might not
normally think of some other places that
you can find great quoting exercises to
ship more stuff are our free code camp
they have awesome exercises along the
way and they also lots of lessons as I'm
sure you guys know if you're checking
out this video but if you don't like
free code camp project
are awesome that's where I got some
ideas like the random quote generator
and there's also if you want to get done
you can compare it to other people have
done the same project which is also
super helpful for JavaScript 3 by West's
boss this is one of my absolute favorite
courses that I always recommend to
people and it's totally free you can go
in and he gives you like 30 bite-sized
sort of projects that you can actually
ship and make things on over about 30
days and this is insanely cool because
it's you don't have to mess around with
your development environment or a
framework or something crazy it's all
vanilla JavaScript there's some really
cool like styling already baked in so
you feel good about it and it feels like
you're getting some quick wins so highly
recommend that course as like a quick
one to get off the ground after you've
brushed up on some of the basics of
JavaScript the next thing it's just like
if you were excited about wearing
something called fear aside about
learning react or react native if you
just really want to understand how
databases work and how to work with them
I'll come up with an idea that just
helps you learn that thing right come up
with an idea that works really cool that
works really well with react and you're
excited about maybe it's totally useless
or silly or whatever who cares like just
make it and just focus on learning that
technology and that's a great way to
build your skill set and then the last
one one of my favorite ones in the world
is like just get paid to actually make
things just get paid I've gotten paid to
do like freelance projects just web
design and they get a little bit of
JavaScript or try out some new CSS
things or whenever I get to put these
things to practice at work it's even
better cuz I you know I'm spending maybe
a few days of like you know my
nine-to-five
or squeezing a little time on a weekend
and like I get recognition for it at
work or I can get work resources or I
get like chunk of my day that I get to
focus on that so and this is especially
good if you are like really busy or it's
hard for you to carve out time on nights
and weekends at home sometimes that
happens sometimes you have kids inside
you have a crazy schedule but if you can
find a way like work with your boss work
with the people
at your company - to get paid to
actually learn this stuff and it makes
something that's valuable for the
company to use or the client to use do
that every time the sooner you can get
to that even if it's just you know HTML
and CSS even if it's just a little bit
of simple JavaScript that's a huge win
because you're getting paid you're
growing your skills and then you can
level up and start doing more stuff
making your own stuff getting paid more
to do cool stuff for the same company
you never know what opportunities that
could unlock it's been super powerful
for me and then what to actually learn
so yeah I've been focusing more like on
all this obviously on how you learn in
the habit to build to learn because I
really do believe that's more important
than like a specific tech stack once you
understand the fundamentals once you
learn understand how to do this stuff
once it's habitual and automatic and you
don't even think about it switching from
Ruby to PHP or from JavaScript you know
whatever the next great thing is isn't
gonna be such a big deal but that being
said it does kind of help to understand
the lay of the land and so there's this
great sort of like web developer roadmap
flow chart that's super helpful at least
when I was getting started to understand
what's out there
kind of where am I out of my journey on
the front end and the back end and what
things gonna keep an eye out for or
learn about so that's super helpful
highly recommend that you check it out
I'm not gonna walk you through it now
but definitely an excellent excellent
resource if you haven't checked it out
before all right
the second habit that I think is super
crucial um when you're if you're gonna
get your dream job in software as I
recommend building a three circle
network so what I mean by that is
normally when people think about
networking they jump straight to like
terrible networking event with like
platters of food and people are like
throwing their business cards at you and
just like it's kind of like a out of
this whole like sleazy used-car salesman
stick and you just feel like people are
talking at each other they're not really
connecting yeah nobody wants that but
what I think
good networking is is just helping
people and being part of a community and
giving back and this starts with what I
call like your inner circle so I think
of it in like these three terms your
inner circle your professional network
and what I call the crowd and so we're
going to start with the inner circle
what is the inner circle your inner
circle when you're starting out
networking is like your mentors your
peers and the people that you are
helping immediately it's like a small
core group of people these are people
that you can like learn from and lean on
for like these 10x big growth decisions
or trajectory that you're on and like
these tough decisions that you're making
these are people that can help keep you
accountable for your side projects that
can help you get introductions for your
first job that can basically you can
turn to for honest and helpful and real
feedback got this idea kind of from like
a like a five-star general I think I
heard about and his habit at all times
was to have three people in his life one
who was a step ahead of him in his
career for someone who had done two
things that he wants to do who has
experience who was wiser older and had
value to pass down to him that he didn't
know to ask for or and he can turn to
that person
when when he needs advice when he needs
help also someone you respect that is
like at your level but it's like best in
class and is doing good work that can
can keep like kind of light a fire on
you and keep you moving forward and show
you what's possible at your level and
you can get honest and real feedback
that maybe isn't doesn't make sense to
get from a mentor and then of course
like you've if you once you get here the
next step that you want to take once you
get that job that opportunity you get to
ship that project it's I really think
you have an obligation or an opportunity
to turn around and help other people who
were who were in your shoes a few months
ago or a few years ago and so always
being willing to help lend a hand to
people and and pass that on pay that
forward so I think so critically
important and and I think everyone
should take the chance to do that I then
there's also your professional network I
think this is what most people think of
when they think of
working I tend to think of this just in
terms of like who can I ask a favor from
with a quick message this is like people
from like professional group of people
from tech Lahoma probably like free code
camp would often fall into this I think
another really critical thing to define
in this stage it's like super connectors
so if you know there's like I have this
friend when I was in college named
Maggie and whenever we work on a group
project where we had to go like we're
working on oppression we had to go like
interview professors or go find other
students who knew but especially the
different things I just asked her hey
who do you know and she didn't send me
over like a list of like all these
people to get in touch with like
immediately oh I know Brad over here oh
I know this professor over here oh I can
call in a favor over here they just know
all these people
you want to know people like that in
your industry and be building those
connections so that when you know if
something horrible happens and you lose
your job like great you can reach out to
that person they can connect you to the
right people all right it's like hey I
really need help with a side project I
need help with this volunteer thing I'm
doing who I don't know who to ask for
who do you know you want those people
who are super deeply connected
especially if that's not your thing you
want to know those people it's so
helpful classmates family friends
relatives former co-workers you know the
point here is like you know more people
than you think you do a lot of times you
tend to discount oh I don't know any
people in software oh I don't know any
people with the kinds of jobs I want to
have but you have friends you have
family of relatives and they might know
people like that so feel free to like
reach out and and connect with those
people and look for the second and third
degree connections who can get you in
the door who can connect you with a
super connector who can show you a
professional group that you didn't know
about this is super key to positioning
yourself to be able to get that job in
six nine 12 24 months whatever that is
and then the crowd this is like who can
I meaningfully help today I'm gonna talk
to them a little bit about like sharing
your bright products and showing what
you're learning but the point is this is
like social media email subscribers
people who visit your website or blog or
watch your videos or
listen your podcast whatever that thing
is but I believe that once you like have
your mentors and your peers in that
close-knit inner circle in place and
once you have a professional network of
people that you can connect with and and
be a part of that you should be like
putting stuff out in the world like in
your space so if you're like really into
react like awesome how can you go help
the react community how can you build a
following how can you you know whether
that's on Twitter that's on YouTube
videos or whether that's teaching other
people how to do something in your
framework like find ways that you can
help other people because that is going
to come back around when you need it
most
especially when it comes to to landing a
job and a lot of times it's it's hard to
see what that'll look like but I've it's
pretty people who build that habit of
helping people on building a crowd and
building an audience it usually comes
back around in a good way to help them
out and it's a huge advantage and this
is just like totally been a key factor
in like my journey like there's no way
I'd be diving as deeply into marketing
or software development if it weren't
for like this huge crowd of passionate
talented people who have like introduced
me to new tech got me like involved in
communities and got me excited about it
like introduced new strategies for
projects and code and doing exciting
things giving me feedback I like blog
posts and podcasts and courses and side
pressure ideas and everything and like
we talked about like actually keeping me
accountable the ship work whether it's
you know just like a blog post or a
video or like putting together an API or
whatever it is like having people around
you at each of those levels the inner
circle your professional network the
crowd is gonna be a huge help to
actually getting stuff done and there
are like lots of other things that I
learned in this sort of like networking
journey but I think one of the main ones
that that's helpful for everyone is just
that don't get discouraged when people
don't get back to you right away
with your follow-up endless follow-up
and needs to be your new default I think
so many times when I was reaching out
about jobs and when I'd meet a great
connection for someone I wanted to learn
from sometimes they they wouldn't get
back to me right away and it was so easy
for me at first to tribute that to like
oh they don't like me they don't think
I'm any good or maybe they're they're
just like hostile towards me but usually
it's just busyness people are so crazy
busy and I know I'm busy so many times
and and so sometimes I won't get back to
people as quickly as I should but it's
you know that person might think I'm mad
at them but I'm not I'm not I'm just
like super busy and if they keep
following up I want to help them I want
to connect with them I want to get to
know them I'm so just making the endless
follow up your new default is so
critical to making that happen
I got encouraged by the story one time
by this the CEO who wants to followed up
with an investor 48 times in a row
without a response and then on you know
forty seven times you know he'd reach
out every few days every few weeks
whatever and and he would leave an email
leave a message and just didn't get back
to him on the 48 time that investor got
back to my said oh sorry I've just had a
lot of fires burning I've been super
busy
can you meet tomorrow morning and they
met and he invests in his company a lot
of times you know people who you want to
work with or who are doing great stuff
are just super busy and so the more you
can I do follow up well half the endless
follow up that continual follow up go
the distance with that to help them out
a lot of times as long as you're not
doing that in an obnoxious way as long
as you're doing that from a good place
and you're doing it and doing the hard
work of having something to show having
something to bring to that meeting
making that worthwhile for both of you
that can actually be a great great
experience for everyone involved and so
what this is like a general fault that I
scheduled that I've used before for jobs
or getting coffee or just like finding
mentors or things like that I've just
like reaching out and then making sure
that I follow up like after two days
after four days after we
for a few weeks and on and on and on to
make sure that I don't let that slip
through the cracks and that if somebody
doesn't work out it's not because I was
too lazy or forgetful to do them the
courtesy of like actually following
through all right last habit number
three sharing your byproducts this is a
super key idea I believe and the reason
why why does it matter a bike sharing
your byproducts well so what does this
mean let me share what this means first
so if you're following all the stuff I
talked about you're connecting with
people you're your learning building
first you're becoming a learning machine
by creating these quick wins by creating
the right inputs and the right forcing
functions to force you to put stuff out
in the world you're gonna be learning
cool stuff you'll be like you know
messing around in JavaScript you'll be
building websites you'll be creating
apps you all these great side project
ideas you'll you'll learn new things so
you'll be creating stuff and it's
tempting to just just let that out and
just let that sit you know I shut that
thing great awesome move on to the next
thing but what I believe you should do
and I learned this from like this this
article from the base camp folks who are
it makes this awesome app they put a
lotta great blog posts unto the world
but about like selling your byproducts
and about like if you are learning these
things in real time if you are you the
byproduct of that is like hey you have
like a cool learning that went along
with it as you were learning this as you
are navigating it as you were
encountering new problems and finding
new ways to solve it other people would
benefit from that if they just knew what
you knew if you just documented the
things that you learned the things we
worked on and put it out in the world
and a blog post in a video in a social
media post anyway even a lightning talk
in a real person event speaking that
would help someone else and so often
people feel like they need to to be a
guru way to have it all together to have
it figured out so they like put on their
Creator cap and they feel like they have
to be some social media influence or or
have to have done this for 30 years and
know everything inside and out and write
the book on it but that's actually not
true
you can help people by just documenting
your honest experience of what you've
been learning
and to share that in a quick lightning
talk sure then in a quick social media
post and a tweet and a quick screencast
and that can help people that is the
byproduct of the hard work in the
learning that you've already been doing
so why not so the reason why sharing
your byproduct is so impactful is
because it helps others first off which
is so fulfilling and you can help other
peoples you get to help them too that
feels really good it is worthwhile the
deal just for that but beyond that when
you help other people you end up helping
yourself too when you when you help
people out in your community they're
gonna want to help you out too if you
help them learn anything they want to
hook you up with a neat job they'll want
to help your underside project they'll
want to help you fix that bug send
people your way when you're hiring
whatever that is you want to always be
helping on and giving back to the
community and then it just creates
opportunities by showing your work
putting it out on github sharing the
process of why you built something a
certain way that shows people how you
think and people will be attracted to
that people notice that stuff and then
people who some people who might have
overlooked you before realized Wow okay
this person actually knows what they're
doing I really want to work with them I
really want to hear them speak I really
want to to hop on a side project with
them or invite them in you never know
what's gonna happen but people can't
discover the cool stuff you're doing if
you don't tell them about it it's simple
but it's so easy to overlook some
practical ways that this has looked for
me it's just like whenever I get a
chance to public speak I always say yes
alright it's so it was really like
intimidating to jump that do it first
before I started public speaking it was
my number one fear but once I hopped in
once I muscled through it like it has
been so rewarding and even though it's
been scary I've never regretted saying
yes to a public speaking opportunity
last year at at Tech Lahoma Thunder
plains at this conference I'd never done
a lightning talk before which is a line
attack it's like a five minute
presentation in front of people kind of
impromptu on just one simple idea that
you want to share
so I gave one unlike how to market your
side project and how to find great ideas
and I gave that talk and one of the
people in the audience was a developer
at tailwind and so afterwards like he
came up to me as I came in great talk
and we got to talking about his
lightning talk about react and he
introduced me to his coworker and we all
chatted and then they introduced me to
the CEO of tailwind
that went really well and they got me
connected with the director of marketing
and that got the whole interview process
started and I eventually ended up
hopping on board their team so it's okay
if you actually connect the dots like me
stepping out and giving a lightning talk
I actually opened the door to me getting
like my dream job at a tech startup in
Oklahoma City it's kind of crazy to
think about like if I would have like
sat down and been too timid to do that
that might not have happened or it might
not have happened this fast which is
crazy
so again when when it came up my second
year at Thunder Plains of course I did a
lightning talk and I didn't you never
feel as ready as you want to you don't
you never feel like those butterflies
are like that it gets totally easy or
not scary but it's always worth it and I
always recommend doing that the other
thing when it comes to documenting this
stuff is just like keep it simple pick
one primary channel and just stick to it
if you love being on video just do
videos if you're on Instagram all the
time give it a shot just do a quick
instrument post when you're coding and
share what you're working on if you like
writing stuff out in blog posts cool
awesome that's great
write a blog post after you finish like
learning something or shipping some code
do you have some friends and you just
like talking about the latest and
greatest like things and you know Python
that you're working on cool awesome sort
of Python podcasting and just document
this stuff every week and just have a
fun time doing it if you pick that one
thing and you stick to it it gets way
easier to build a crowd because you're
talking about what you already know you
have this forcing function of hey we're
gonna make a blog post every week I'm
gonna put a podcast out every week and
it could be so so helpful another thing
that I found is really helpful when your
figure out well like what can I really
talk about I feel like I'm rehab
the same stuff that everyone is talking
about we don't need another you know
to-do list tutorial in JavaScript okay
fine like I get that too like you want
stuff that's gonna stand out and is
something that only you can create so at
first I say just go back to Row 1 you
know always be shipping but beyond that
once you get in the habit - or if you
need something a bit different
I find this trick of like you're finding
your superpower really helpful so this
is an idea from like scott adams the
creator of Dilbert and his his idea is
basically that you can could take two
skills so for me like i started growing
my marketing skills like early on and so
i feel really confident that like desk
us and then I also started like learning
to code and software development and
building apps and great okay cool so if
I take the overlap between those two
contrasting specialties that I have
those two skills I have like marketing
and development and so I can combine
those two be like a marketing developer
and find things so okay cool marketing
API is and okay cool how can we build a
bot that helps people on your homepage
and this is called marking things cool
how can i aughtta made my emails in this
cool way that's like a cool marketing
thing and you can find things that most
developers aren't talking about and most
marketers don't know how to do and that
can be super valuable so yours look
different than this but you can find
other things that are in addition to
software development and layer them on
top and that overlap is what you can
talk about that's unique to you and
really valuable and showcases what
you're passionate about what you're good
at which can be make it a lot easier to
get started just documenting this stuff
another great thing about sharing your
byproducts as it makes it so much easier
to come up with ideas for things to
actually make which goes back to one of
the other problems and barriers that you
you run into when you're trying to get
started creating and so I found it
really helpful if you're putting stuff
out of the world that becomes and you
have people that are paying attention on
Twitter on your email list or at meetups
it gets easier to like tap your
community for these insights as you're
ongoing so you can discover pain points
right if you're like really involved in
the JavaScript community and you have
JavaScript friends and they're talking
to them about this
you can maybe discover a need for like a
new package that you could write or a
new open source thing you could start if
you have an idea
if you're starting a following for like
marketers and they're coding things for
them you can put out a quick tweet and
be like hey would it be helpful if I
coded this kind of things and you can
validate ideas quickly and get feedback
from the stuff you're working on which
can be really really helpful it can help
you validate ideas really quickly this
is something that I've actually done as
well I was just like I had an idea for a
side app that I wanted to work on - just
like brush up on some coding skills like
it was like okay what if I could make an
app that'll help people meet up for
coffee and like sync their calendars and
find a free time for both of them so I
just put up a quick thing on LinkedIn
because I'm pretty active on Linkedin
and I get like 41 likes an 18 comment I
got like an list of I followed up with
each and every one of those people one
on one you can see even some lose people
I don't know these people they're
second-degree connections and so I was
still able to connect with him grab
their emails and follow up with him and
I didn't actually end them getting as
far with that app as I wanted yet but
when I have something to show my next
side project I'm gonna plan on like
repeating this process and like reaching
out making a list and reaching out to
people in that way I can I can develop
it fast or come up with more ideas avoid
that block and get more of those quick
wins and always be shipping so and this
just came from like documenting the the
stuff I was gonna work on I didn't I
wasn't even planning to post about this
side project that I was working on us
like how it's small it's silly who
really cares but more people cared than
I thought and so giving this a chance
just documenting it and putting it out
there in the world I was a huge
advantage and I'm super glad that I did
so those are really like the three ideas
in a nutshell that took me from like not
really knowing how the code or feeling
like I want to be a lot of ways hooda
started and stopped so many times to
actually getting my foot in the door
meeting the right people having the
skills built up and sharing what I was
doing to where like I was able to to
join this awesome job at Dylan
and I love going to work every day I
work with some of the best people on the
planet and and I'm so happy that I get
to do it it's exciting it's fresh it's
fun and like I am even more excited for
like my side projects because the things
I'm learning at work like feed into the
things I'm doing outside of work in
coding and marketing in in the people
that I'm meeting and so in the things
the people I'm meeting outside like
feeding right back in the world makes me
more excited and it's such a cool place
to be and so I'm so glad I started those
habits you know like 12 to 18 months ago
of just like putting my learning on
autopilot building those those networks
and hopping in the Oklahoma City
community starting to document my work
these things make such a big difference
over the long run and so that's my
experience again hit me up on LinkedIn
and Twitter email me whatever I'm happy
to talk more about these ideas and what
they're like yeah cool thanks guys so
much we listen I appreciate it
take care